my guest this week is the England rugby
player Maro atojo he's tackled players
on the pitch and politicians to try and
help poorer children I want to ask him
what fires him up the most and how do
you prepare to run at someone and Tackle
them
[Music]
thank you so much for being here it's
lovely to have you in the studio and I
thought I'd start just I'm someone who
studied politics at University and I
know you also studied it and have a big
interest in it and I wonder now you're a
sports star how political are you
allowed to be or how much is that part
of Who You Are
well I guess there's no real limit
to how political you want to be
um I guess is down to you know
individual choice and freedom and how
much you want to you know delve into
that World
um you know Politics as you as you said
something I studied at Uni I did it at
secondary school as well and even since
graduating it's you know it's something
that I've always had had a keen interest
in I think it's it's in our minds a bit
more about sports stars and politics
because of the men's World Cup and
what's been going on or what's not been
going on there and I wonder with that
and that discussion around that whole
whole piece you know do you think it is
actually important for sports stars to
stand up and to to Make Some Noise about
issues that they care about and about
human rights yeah so I I do think it's
important for athletes sports stars to
you know have their opinions heard
um as long as you know they have an
opinion on it
um I I'm not too comfortable with the
the rhetoric of stars or sports stars or
athletes
um being forced to take positions that
they're not comfortable with or maybe
they just don't have an opinion at all
but by all means if there is something
that you believe in if there's a you
know a stance or a position or you know
a campaign that you want to be involved
in I think athletes should feel
emboldened to to do so so there's a
change isn't that on that front and it
was interesting Gary lineker was on this
program not long ago and he was saying
he feels bad for athletes and sports
stars in some ways because they can't
win if they try and say something you
know they get told get back in your box
perhaps by some especially politicians
may say if they don't say something
there can also be attacked for that so
it's it's quite a difficult Terrain in
some ways it is it's uh it's not easy
and I think the best way of of
navigating that space is just try to be
you know authentic
um I think if you're authentic whether
people like it or they don't like it at
least you know you're authentic to
yourself is when perhaps you jump on a
campaign because it's popular or you're
you know you don't really know what
you're talking about with regards to a
certain issue or topic that's when it
can be a little bit wishy-washy but I
think if it comes from an authentic
place and you can always tell if it
comes from an authentic place then by
all means go go ahead well do you follow
football is that allowed as a rugby I'm
an Arsenal fan I'm awesome I never
presume anything it's not always the
same groups that follow the same things
and the same interests but I mean do you
think the England team have been the
England men's team have been bold enough
we saw the German team put their hands
over their mouth in reference to Qatar
censorship and all of that I think the
the men's football team and not in only
just now but if you look at you know
what they've done over the last
18 months 24 months in some of the
positions they've held
um for across different campaigns I
think they've done a lot they've done a
lot to push the conversation forward I
think they've done a lot to raise
awareness or you know just try and move
the needle a little bit
um you can always make an argument that
you could do more you could do less
but the focus should be on
the people who are organizing the event
the focus should be on uh the
administrators to make whatever stance
that they they want to make I think you
know I think they have a track record of
doing doing good and you know standing
up for things things they believe in you
did step into British politics a little
bit with a small P um during the the
lockdown the covered lockdowns when you
talked about the need for children to
have access to laptops and to bridge
that digital divide when we were having
schools shut and education was being
interrupted why did you choose to do
that and how did you find that
experience
um I guess why I chose to do it was
brought to my attention
um this this campaign I guess
um you know this campaign was wasn't
started by me it was started you know
there's been a lot of people who've been
doing some good work in in that space
But essentially there was uh the gap
between the The Haves and the Have knots
was getting wider and wider with with
regards to children's education and
education is often
what we talk about in society as you
know the great leveler is the is the
tool we use for social Mobility it's a
tool we use to you know to get people
out of poverty and what was happening in
that situation in in lockdown was the
those who had money who could afford
data had iPads had computers laptops Etc
were able to continue with their
education and those who didn't were
falling further and further behind and
you know they the people who are falling
further and further behind were the
exact people who you know we needed to
help who needed education perhaps more
so than others
um so that was you know the the driving
the driving force behind myself getting
involved in in that campaign and how was
the experience it you know it was it was
it was it was a cool experience it was
good it was it was it was nice to know
that you're having an impact on some
children's lives and have a small of a
way do you like what's the latest on
that I mean I know we're not in
lockdowns anymore thankfully
um but that's been a concern hasn't it
the the exacerbation of inequality and
we're starting to see some of the
results of what happened to Children
especially during that time do you have
any update on that do you stay yeah so
the the digital divide obviously it's in
a slightly better position now because
children are back at school
um they're attending classes they're you
know normal school life as it were has
has resumed but you know the digital
divide is still something that is
ongoing the then education secretary of
of the UK Gavin Williamson high-profile
British politician uh he confused you
with a different black sports star the
footballer for Manchester United England
national Marcus rashford
do you remember when you heard about
that where you were and what your
reaction was yeah it was all it was all
a little bit odd to be honest
um
so I think I was at home and I just
noticed my phone was like pinging off
your notifications and I was a little
bit confused what was going on so then
um people started sending me articles
then I looked at what was going on so
then it all started to make sense to me
and I mean we dismayed were you
um so yeah it was all it was all very
very surprising
um it was all very surprising he uh you
know the story was that he I think it
was in had it was undertaken an
interview and he confused me with Marcus
rashford or vice versa I can't quite
remember
um so yeah it was all it was all it was
all a bit surprising but he did you know
he he called me
um thereafter we spoke he apologized so
what was that conversation night it was
it was fine okay it was fine he he
called he said it was um an honest
mistake and he hopes I took no offense
to it
um but he was he said it was a long
interview and he you know just messed up
his words right
okay well it's uh it's always good to be
able to ask people when they've been in
the middle of something how it was for
them let's talk about what you do dude
which is obviously play rugby at the
highest possible level I love getting
into which we're going to get into what
people eat just generally and I know you
have to eat certain things to get
through this and keep up a certain level
but how do you prepare before a
tournament
how do you prepare I guess
um the is is it happens in many stages I
guess before a tournament the I think
the first part of preparation is is
physical preparation so getting yourself
in the right physical prep and you know
every every athlete that will look a
little bit different
um but for me that involves a load of
Fitness work I know those strength work
um I I was fortunate enough to go to
Portland this summer with with Under
Armor we did a little pre-season Camp
there
um just getting the body right
recovering well I'm exposing myself to
new different type of training methods
um but yeah it's just a mixture of
physical recovery physical preparation
mental preparation then once that's done
you know the team the team gets together
and the team trains to to get going
what's mental preparation right
well it's it's it's mainly around like
performance really so it's uh for me so
when I mentally prepare for games it's
visualizing what situations may happen
it's you know getting myself emotionally
right forget for games you know rugby is
a very emotional
um it's very emotional game it won't
work I wouldn't necessarily have thought
of that word it's when I say is emotion
like
is not normal to you know run at people
it's not normal to hit people it's not
normal to you know get in a scrum and
launch yourself at someone else so it's
and all those
actions you know for it to be effective
um you know you need to have a certain
level of emotion in in that you need
that you need to care about what you're
doing you need to that needs to be like
a it's not just something uh you know
just
sending an email is is a lot is a much
more emotive
um sport is there anyone uh in public
life or famous that you've ever thought
that would be quite good fun to tackle
yeah uh well there was I I'm pretty sure
I remember I think there was a cliff of
Boris Johnson tackling a kid there is
everybody with a rugby ball which was an
interesting look yeah yeah I think oh he
I think he had to talk with him or ran
completely over him yeah he made sure he
beat it he definitely beat him forever
um who would I like to tackle I'm not
sure you know it sounded like you wanted
to take him take up Boris Johnson at
that point for that kid oh maybe maybe
the kid tapped me and tapped me I'll
help them out but I don't know I don't
know yeah I don't I don't normally
think of it think of it like that no no
fair enough
um you talk about children in the Next
Generation I know you were 11 when you
started playing and things change like
you're talking about your nutrition as
well and and there has been a lot of
talk lately about safety and also in
particular
headgear and how to protect players
professional players and younger to
protect their heads are you are you
concerned about that and some of the
issues that have been raised about uh
concerns about long-term memory issues
and the need for for helmets of some
kind
um I think you know as a player you have
to be oh you don't have to be but it is
more than reasonable to be concerned
about the long-term effects of of the
game especially in this current climate
where it's you know come to the
Forefront and it's you know in the news
a lot
um and when we have former players
who've come out and said or come out and
and you know they now have uh issues
which go back to their playing days
resulting from concussions so you is
more than sensible or reasonable to be
to be concerned with that what I would
say and and the only caveat to that
which makes me more comfortable with you
know continuing to play rugby is you
know the the protocols and systems that
we have as players now in comparison to
you know the early 2000s early 2010s is
way different is it way different
um the in terms of even
not only the processes but in terms of
the the culture in around concussion is
totally different
so I started playing rugby in 2006 at my
school and probably from about 2006 to
about
2013 14 or so
what I experienced was the culture
within rugby that the concussion wasn't
really seen as a serious injury so if
someone was to you know get concussed or
get knocked out on the field
it was almost seen as an act of weakness
for them to come off the field as a
result of their headlock
however now is almost the complete
opposite once someone has a head knock
you know your teammates are no longer
telling you hey come on get up get up we
need you the thinking about that person
or that individual first
they're saying no you need to get out
because you need to look after your head
um so even the culture in and around the
conversation has
shifted immeasurably
um and in addition to that more science
more medical research so
um you know I recently went through a
concussion protocol last summer so I'm
quite familiar with my process and it's
very very thorough now in comparison to
what it was do you think helmet should
be the norm well there's I'm not here
I'm no scientist I'm no doctor so
um I'll just caveat that with regards to
anything I say but um
they
not all scrum got
um scrum hats
um are proven to stop concussion or
reduce concussion
um I know there's a there's a scrum hat
on the market now that makes that makes
that claim however I'm not too sure on
you know the actual you know scientific
research behind it
um so it's not it's not as easy as
saying wear a scrum hat then that
reduces your likelihood of concussion
um so it's it's a bit more complicated
than that the women's game the women's
rugby game which is coming up just like
it's actually probably behind where the
women's football game is in terms of
it's still reach and popularity but
there was a piece I read recently which
said that for the first time ever the
men's game could learn perhaps something
from the women's game when it comes to
how many head injuries or head
assessments there are just because of
playing properly and you know doing
things in a certain way I wonder what
you make of the the women's game in
comparison and also the influence of
that is that something that features
when you're thinking about how to play
and the team
um the the two very different you know
the the the the two obviously we both
play rugby but there's two very
different styles and
um of the game and other things that we
can learn of course the things that we
can learn
um and vice versa
um but you know what I think has been
amazing has been you know the growth of
the women's game over the last 10 years
in terms of skill in terms of uh
participation in terms of viewing uh
recently there was the you know Women's
World Cup yeah and it was in New Zealand
and you know the amount of people that I
I knew they were waking up at like five
years
to watch watch their game and to see
their growth um even just even in
England is has been amazing you know the
only shame is is that it was in New
Zealand if that World Cup was in England
or in a time zone which was a bit more
friendly to you know English viewers I
think we would have seen a similar
phenomena phenomenon to what we saw with
the with the women's football we'll see
how we'll see how that goes do your just
on the point of view of safety not not
necessarily to do with concussion or
headwear do your family struggle to
watch you play do they get nervous about
you getting hurt still I don't think so
um I know you're at the top
I don't think so my it used to be my mum
but now and did she find it difficult I
think she used to find like the
collisions like like yeah that made her
wince a little bit but
I don't think so they don't express to
me that that anytime I'm injured they're
always like oh be careful be careful be
careful but I don't think they struggle
too much
um with with that aspect of the game
they come to pretty much every game they
do okay so um if if if if they do if
they do uh struggle with them it's not
stopping them from coming to watch the
games what what would you say the
culture of
um the rugby Community is like as a
player you know we hear a lot about
football we hear a lot about abuse a lot
about things needing to improve do you
think Rugby's has got it in a better
place I think rugby is Miles Ahead of
football
I think rugby you know you can never go
to a you know I'm an Arsenal fan you
can't go to the Emirates and have
Arsenal and Tottenham fans sitting right
next to each other and expect a fight
not to happen or you know the police not
to swarm in you know you can go to
assassins our local uh London Rivals are
harlequins you can go to any assassins
harlequins game you know assassin's fans
will be sitting here Harley Quinn's fans
will be sitting here and that's the same
with you know International around with
International rivalries so it was
England Wales in the football recently
if that was in in in rugby you know you
have English fans sitting here Welsh
fans sitting here they'll always be
drinking together laughing together
that's happened a lot England Wales and
rugby
um you know they'll both be firstly
supporting their teams but the you know
the dynamic and the whole atmosphere is
totally different so is what why do you
think that is I mean is that there's
that quote isn't there uh I always get
it wrong so I've written it down
football is a game for gents played by
Hooligans and Rugby's a game for
Hooligans played by gentlemen I mean I
don't know if that yeah ever rang true
yeah I don't know I don't know that's
that's the that's the old adage yes
um but I don't know I think
the the the the spirit with within rugby
is just totally different especially
amongst the the supporters it's
um I think rugby supporters perhaps go
to games to have a good time as opposed
to go to games to you know hurl abuse
that one another maybe that's uh
probably the key difference yeah but
it's just interesting how it's grown up
completely differently in that way and
and why that is I mean do you want do
you think more kids also should be
exposed to rugby talking about the
digital divide but you know especially
in the UK especially in England you know
this there's a real class divide about
who gets to play rugby some of the time
not all of the time but football is
generally offered at all schools rugby
is not yeah rugby rugby needs to grow
rugby needs to grow and you know rugby
needs to look at ways in which it can
expand into different markets different
areas different schools different
demographics because you know rugby as a
sport it needs to grow and it needs to
go into these markets that don't
typically play rugby or aren't typically
you know associated with rugby in order
to achieve that growth yeah I think
rugby is very good at singing to the
choir what what where I think rugby can
improve is is in its Outreach isn't it
how it's marketed is and how it tries to
get new people to to come into the fold
yeah I mean it's it'll be interesting to
see how that changes also maybe with the
women's game and and the appeal of how
that that moves on you've said you don't
want to be a pundit actually and I'm not
trying to bring your your creator
clothes but what's that like though when
you try and think Beyond because you you
obviously do have a lot of interests and
it isn't inauthentic for you to share
views on things what else takes your
fantasy do you reckon or what other
things am I interested in yeah no to
take to perhaps be for the future
um oh well I think uh
you know I think retirement from rugby
is something that is in the back of
pretty much all rugby players or all
athletes minds and I think it's
important to to have a think about it
and you know so you can plan that next
next stage
um I'm I'm a big African art Enthusiast
um you know the dream one day would have
will be to have a gallery African art
gallery so hopefully we can make that
happen I want to do a bit more
philanthropic work
um I want to be involved in a bit of
business I probably want to go into
business
um after rugby
um so how old are you now I'm 28 and
what when is a retirement age uh from
I'm thinking mid 30s okay I think you're
like 35 and then you're done I think
that would be a good time to wrap it up
so I still got
still got a little bit of running of
these old legs yeah yes you do and
you've got some work to do before France
we do it's lovely to talk to you thank
you so much thank you thank you very
much and thank you for being with us
until we meet again take care and
goodbye
[Music]